the layer heil pen show
[Music]
sponsored by step finance
your go to d5 portfolio manager on
solana
luna if you're just getting into bitcoin
it's the perfect place to start
[Music]
hey guys and welcome back to the leia
highway plan show it's gonna be another
interesting conversation all about
crypto this time um and we're gonna
learn a lot are we in a bear market i
don't know yet so let's find out but
before we jump in this particular um
podcast as you know is sponsored by
blockfi you can actually get around 250
dollars when you sign up um and deposit
money with them so i use them and i
really enjoy it the link if you want to
join is in the description and in the
comment section so check that out um and
it's also powered by iconplus capital
the vc firm so definitely check them out
as well so joining me today is somebody
who kind of just came on the scene out
of nowhere i'm super excited to learn
about him it is cousin crypto josh
what's up what's up thank you for having
me
yeah it's good to meet you i feel like
we connected a while ago but i've never
been able to
know who you are or learn about you so
how are you doing
i'm doing good can't complain you know
actually i mean i can't complain a
little bit about the market you know
it's not great um but we'll get there
yeah i'm hoping so so you kind of
popped out of nowhere um that tick tock
video came online i don't think you even
had a twitter did you at the time nope
didn't have a twitter um but i saw my
opportunity and i capitalized on that
no that's great yeah so i was just uh
you know i was in college i was at the
university at the time
i was at arizona state and i really
enjoyed it um but
i just didn't really enjoy the whole
school aspect of it which wasn't great
like the academic aspect um
i felt like you know you were kind of in
a system that didn't create a reward
creativity and it just wasn't for me so
i was looking for another way out and i
knew going into college it was not going
to be a four-year thing but i didn't
have a back-up plan at the time um so
you know i was doing crypto but
obviously you know 2018 2019
that wasn't gonna be that wasn't looking
like a way out
so i started doing tick tock and i said
to my friends yo i'm gonna start dieting
i'm gonna lose a bunch of weight and i'm
gonna give out workout advice and i'm
gonna pop off because of it a lot of my
friends like laughed at me like i didn't
even have tik tok downloaded um
so i just started doing that you know
exactly that started posting workout
advice um dieting supplements all that
good stuff
one day someone asked me you know where
do you get your money and this is when
crypto kind of started you know going
off again solana was one of my early
trades um and that started really moving
so i just made a video
and at the time i was living in a frat
house so people found that amusing too
and i just made you know shirley's video
explaining you know i'm in crypto i do
this i do that that got thrown up on
twitter and immediately i was like okay
well this is getting views i'm going to
make a twitter account real quick pump
out a couple videos we'll see how i do
you know go from there and it really you
know just snowballed kind of just took
the momentum from there
yeah i remember everyone was just like
who is this guy why doesn't he have why
doesn't have twitter so you made
yourself a twitter account um okay so
you're you were in college um first or
second or third or fourth year where
were you so i was a sophomore i was my
first semester sophomore year what is
that second year i mean second year
second yeah so okay so for my second
year okay and why did you i don't
understand you said that you felt there
was a disconnect with the system you
felt like
university or college wasn't the way to
go talk to me about that well for
example you know in the states um
arizona state and it's not one of the
more expensive universities um without a
scholarship and being out of state it's
50 grand a year which
you know that's a lot of money and so my
class was the first entire year i was a
business major business entrepreneurship
which again i feel like it's a problem
because entrepreneurship is not
something you can really teach you know
it's something you're kind of born with
um at least that's my view
so i was taking business
entrepreneurship and out of my six
classes i had
one business class which was once a week
for 40 minutes and then i had one cis
class which was microsoft excel which
was decent as well um that was for one
hour twice a week the rest of my classes
were nothing to do with business i took
gender studies stress management you
took gender studies weight sociology
like a complete random group of stuff
wait what is gender studies i honestly
couldn't tell you um i didn't learn much
but
you know it's kind of just one of those
classes where you just got to sit there
and you know you're blank and it's over
and it's just like what did i learn so
that was kind of my whole views i was
like i'm not paying 50 grand a year to
do this and a lot of kids are okay with
it because growing up you know in the
states the drinking age is 21. and if
you have strict parents who don't let
you go out don't let you drink during
high school you only get that freedom
when you get to college so they're okay
with you know pissing away 50 grand a
semester because it's the first time
they've had freedom and you know while
partying and everything especially
arizona state being known for it is fun
like i wanted to set up my life you know
that's more important for me i'd rather
get myself set up now um and be able to
be financially set when i'm younger you
know i don't want to be 60 years old on
the golf course with my boys like that's
i'm already i'm already old i've already
got one foot in the grave so i want to
set myself up now so you know hopefully
early 30s i'm doing that kind of stuff
i just i'm just like gobsmacked at the
whole gender studies thing that's insane
because in england it's not like that
like in england when you
do
you study something at university like
you study that we don't study anything
else it's crazy and so like what you
have here is you have community college
which a lot of kids do do for the first
two years um which
i would honestly if i had it back again
it would definitely be worth it because
those first two years yeah you don't
really study your actual major it's only
when you get to your third and fourth
year do they narrow it down and it's
just like
you know same thing like i'm like
learning like calculus and stuff which
again i've never math has never been my
strong point and even to this day you
know in the industry that i'm in
everyone's like oh bro how do you get
the co i don't i still don't you don't
need to know that kind of stuff in my
opinion um you know i've just i've never
really used that stuff in my life
um and i just i couldn't justify paying
that amount of money and then like i
said on top of that it's not like you're
learning anything
that you're gonna take into the real
world so i was just like i cannot
believe that i'm paying this amount of
money getting this out of it and on top
of it it is taking away four years of
your life and it's four years when you
know you're 18 to 22 that's when you got
the most energy the most fire that's
when you're gonna be you know the most
productive so
i was just like i can't do this and you
know there's plenty of examples of
people that have gone to university
become successful people that are
dropped out so for me it's just you know
i'm not like anti-anti-college for some
people they need it they cannot survive
on their own they need to be told what
to do when to do it um and for those
people you know go ahead do it um and
you can stay in the rat race you know
get a nine to five but that was another
thing i don't like kissing off so like i
don't want to have a boss that i have to
you know this is asked to climb up the
ranks do this do that so i just
immediately i was like when i saw my
opportunity i was like i'm out and i'll
never forget the day i was asked uh i
was picked on in class to like speak
about our chapter that we read the night
before
i hadn't read the chapter the night
before so it was you know i just came up
on screen i was like you know what this
has been great it's been real um i don't
think it's for me though and
dropped out right there and then but
like i said like i knew going into it
college was not going to be for me but i
didn't have a backup plan and like that
would be my advice you need to have a
backup plan a lot of people
will drop out without a set plan and
that's a problem because you know now
you have no degree you have no direction
going forward um you got to have one or
the other
yeah i think loads of people go to
university because they don't know what
they want to do
so like there's obviously the partying
and the drinking but it's also a way to
procrastinate adulthood um
so
so what happened you you dropped out you
obviously had you blown up on on tick
tock because of fitness by that point
yeah so i was just posting um like
fitness stuff and again pretty much in
every industry that i've learned now um
you know any industry on the planet
there's a lot of and a lot of
lies to it so with same thing with the
fitness industry um you know i just kept
it real from the start and i didn't
you know in crypto how you have
people promoting you know coins or
you know undisclosed promos um the
fitness industry you have people that
will take anabolic steroids say that
they're natural athletes then promote a
protein or pre-workout say that this is
you know i take this and this is why i
look like x um and then people go out
and buy that and that's you know
scamming so you know i just kept it real
same thing with fitness um started
popping off on there but
the money the money was decent but not
nearly enough to like drop out of school
again if i was dropping out i want to
make sure that i'm set up at least for
the next five to ten years because i
don't have a degree you know i don't
have a business so if hits the fan
i need to be okay um and fitness was
it just it wasn't enough money um but
then you know when crypto and everything
started going off um at the same time it
was kind of just both of them merged
together and i was like all right well
now i have tick-tock i have fitness if
that doesn't work i have crypto um it's
kind of enough for me to just pull out
um and even like the fitness like i
stopped for a little just like just
because tick tock is
the worst platform for me personally um
i don't know what the thief is with me
it's just oh it's
any video that i post so like if i post
a shirt on this video which was like my
thing it now gets taken down for minor
safety even though i'm 21 years old um
yeah a lot of them you know it's just
like it'll get flagged or it'll get
shadow banned if you're a new creator
looking to start out i mean tick tock
can really change your life it did it
changed mine in
a matter of months um i mean within one
month like i had 10 000 followers the
next month i had 30. i remember i got
banned at 30 000 followers and i almost
gave up i was like damn i just put in so
much work like i'm done with this thank
goodness i didn't because again you know
all this crypto and stuff i would have
been i would have been fine without
social media but i'm sure as you know
like being an influencer in the crypto
space as well opens up huge doors huge
connections um and you definitely profit
a lot more so it's like tick-tock really
just from like posting like garage
workout videos like me just in my frat
house in arizona i just i woke up one
day and i was like i've had enough of
this because i also used to drink quite
a bit you know south african culture
it's not it's not something i'm proud of
but you know i did and it obviously
packed on the weight um so i kind of
just one day during quarantine it's
really easy to get you know slip you can
go
there's a lot of people that choose the
path all right i'm gonna better myself
i'm gonna get healthy i'm gonna get fit
but during a time like cloven and
quarantine it's very easy to go the
other way of you know okay i'm just
gonna sit on the couch drink you know
all that and that was kind of the road
that i took at first um and then yeah
just one day woke up and like i always
you know people ask me like how i do it
and it's like you gotta want it bad
enough like there was there was a time
like i've only just got back and working
out and stuff like the last month and a
half um
prior to that like the last six months i
completely stopped because like i got
comfortable with the money and stuff
that i've made in crypto and i thought
that was all that i needed which was
just not true like i watched my mental
health slip and everything um
but
yeah you know
it's been uh
it's been crazy the last few months um
and sick talk really just like that
decision one day waking up and
especially at my age like my group of
friends tic toc was something we made
fun of um and you know it was an app
that none of us had and it was like a
huge risk for me like personally taking
it like i took a lot of at the
beginning um but again the career that
you can build yourself with it is
unbelievable and just you know i'm
living proof i started off with fitness
i was never a bodybuilder before this i
never before i started working out you
know over quarantine and tick tock and
stuff i'd worked out maybe like one two
months at a time with my friends in high
school at the gym you know that kind of
stuff never died or anything
within a few months like i was this
signed athlete with steel i was their
second highest paying healthy giving out
advice doing all this stuff people were
benefiting from it and i think that was
the craziest thing for me i never in my
life like expected to inspire people or
like help people and i just know from
being a fat kid how
shitty that is and like losing weight is
the greatest feeling on the planet and
when i had a bunch of you know little
kids in my dms being like yo bro you've
essentially like changed my life like
this and that i had a kid in the gym the
other day come up to me and told me like
he was like kind of like shaking he's
like oh bro the reason i started working
out and for me like that's such a cool
thing because you know working out and
fitness is something that can be a part
of your life for the rest of your life
and it's going to change you for the
positive so yeah just like a word of
advice like if you're out there and like
tired of like doing you know nine to
five and this and that start a tick tock
like it's that it is that easy you know
people like to over complicate that
i also i got my main account taken down
um i restarted up a second one which i
don't really post on because it's
flagged and you know emotions get taken
down but i ran up like 150 000 like
followers on that one in a couple months
too you know it's very it's very doable
and the crazy part about it is you can
post content that you like and like
content that you're interested so i
think that's what's really cool about it
though but
yeah
that's amazing i really commend you um
for just turning your life around so
many people just play victim um
especially doing quarantine i mean i've
i've see you'll see this as well like
i've seen you know my friends go from
university and you know we're now like
in our 20s mid-20s and like they're not
doing anything nobody's doing anything
and they're just wasting away and
quarantine and it's it's so crazy to see
so yeah i really commend you for just
creating a life that you love i think
that's amazing not enough people do it
they just
um
but like so how did you so you how did
you start making money with crypto what
did you do what was the beginning
so the very beginning so i started like
i first started looking at this stuff at
like the end of 2016. i was 16 years old
i'm 21 now um and so like 2017 was when
i really started putting money in and
obviously like
i got up like i lost a lot of
money like did you buy it
i bought like dragon chain um
coin was like one of like my first
purchases um what was that
it was when like icos and stuff were
puffing with ian balina
and there was that one that came out i
forget the name it launched on finance
um
everyone is talking about how it's going
to be the next big thing same as dragon
chain oh disney partnerships this and
that
went all in just got absolutely murked
um but then at the same time i was at
the 2017 conference in miami and that's
where i had this friend um one of my
dad's close friends like a family friend
of ours um he got in a crypto real early
and he at one point had the largest mine
in north america like a big ball at this
time wow yeah this dude had money
and so he flew from south africa um for
the conference and he knew uh charlie
shrimp and he introduced me to charlie
and we went out um and we had like some
drinks and stuff and charlie like you
know you would look at charlie and you'd
think oh like this guy's just a computer
dude he knows how to get on it charlie
knows how to do it
so
um i had like a lot of fun with them and
charlie actually ended up offering me
like an internship um in florida with
him so in 2018
uh when it was my summer because i was
still in high school i flew over there
and i interned with him for a bit
that was when um again like icos and
everything with ian balina like had
still been popping off all that
that was when i came across solana and i
found it like ico like because i was
that was what i was looking at was icos
like i really wanted to make you know
get into those
and so on i came across like i was like
oh this looks this looks wet and so yeah
obviously i was there with charlie and
all them and i got asked them and they
were like oh yeah you know this this
does like if it can do what it promises
like this is going to be a hit
and so
i obviously could not get pre-sell
because i was and i was like a little
kid
they weren't giving me pre-sale so i had
to buy it you know after it launched and
everything
it obviously that was like peak bear
market and so like for a year felt like
two you know it felt like multiple years
we just went sideways um didn't really
make any money and not that i lost
interest but i was like there's just no
point in checking my portfolio anymore
so i just stopped looking at it and i
feel like that's a key that a lot of
people miss is that you do you just
gotta put it away buy it buy that
you like you know fundamentally you
believe in it you see it being in a few
years um and you know just put it away
and so i did that and then
you know 20 when was it like maybe like
beginning like 2020 or like towards the
end of 2020 was when it really started
going um and again being around from
2017 i was not gonna just watch my bags
come back this time like there's
absolutely no way i was gonna let that
happen so i started making money from
crypto around then um
and again i was still my parents at that
point were still paying for me and stuff
i was still
you know like a kid um but once i
started making money from crypto which
was actually like one of like the best
feelings ever like i could go like
completely independent and like
everything was like mine like i
supported me like you know groceries
like it's a small thing but like even
just like going to get groceries and
like i can buy whatever i want and it's
all my money um like that was cool so
yeah then that um and then honestly like
a lot of the money that i made too was
just from staking because i've just been
staking my stuff for so long um and then
i kind of just will you know sell my
rewards as profit take that um as
passive income and then try and hold the
majority of stuff as long as possible so
like solana obviously i ended up holding
like that was for multiple years um
because obviously when you're holding it
you know for over a year long term
capital gains comes into play which is
like you know you're paying half of your
tax now um so that was where when i
really started making the money and then
also like from tiktok like the money
that i had made from the fitness
industry just from like protein codes
like supplements like um you know i had
a discount code for a clothing company i
took all of that as well and put that in
the crypto um and the majority of it you
know i just i would buy and i'll try and
hold it for at least three months um
yeah party was like another early one
that i just bought and hulled for yours
um v change same thing and you know
people think this stuff is easy but it's
not like you it's not you just gotta buy
it and it's so simple buy
low hold it you're so high that is all
there is to it but it is so much deeper
than that you know you gotta hold like
today's you know days like the other day
where we're down 40 30
it's it's hard it's not that easy
but you have to know
what to buy right and
you got the wrong stuff the first time
around you seem to have gotten the right
stuff this time around um you know you
know what you're staking so how do you
navigate everything that there is out
there i mean even i find it so hard to
know you know like what is a good
project and what's not so how do you
start so step one that i've actually uh
that was kind of like a hard like pull
swallow that took me a while to
understand is and including myself you
know um don't listen to influences
influences nine times out of ten the
majority of them are pushing stuff um
you know for their benefits um and
there's you know in my opinion there's a
reason there's a lot of people that are
anonymous because they're doing things
you know that people might not they
might not be comfortable doing with
putting their face behind it um so step
one would be
you know there's obviously there's the
exception there's those couple
influences that have you know
crazy amounts of money hundreds of
millions billions that have been in
since real early and like they don't
need to do that kind of stuff you know
they've earned a reputation that's a
little different um so i'd say that's
number one just knock that out the park
you get rid of half of them real quick
um number two for me is the team um
because at the end of the day no matter
what the project is no matter what the
idea behind it is the team is the one
that's going to be executing it and so
ultimately like you know you're
investing in the idea but
you're investing in a team um if they
can't execute it doesn't matter how
good of a project how sick it is it's
just not gonna happen um so i look at
the team and then number three for me um
which i don't feel like
i feel like it's been you know people
have looked at it recently but like hype
is a big one like there's a lot of good
projects out there that have solid
fundamentals but they just don't know
how to market they don't spend any money
on marketing which is a huge problem
because
everyone else is spending money on
marketing um and they kind of just sit
there you know so there's you know
there's plenty of them um i know like
for example hbar is a project that i
like but like hasn't really done
anything i haven't heard of them yeah so
it's just like so like a lot of people
like think that they
i'm not like too big on it i don't own
any um but so the reason why i don't own
any is because it's all over tik tok and
everyone is like yo like this and that
but a lot of people like on tech talk
prefer the technology over blockchain so
i don't know we'll see we'll see how
that goes but yeah there's like there's
a lot of projects out there that have
they tick all the boxes but then when it
comes to like social media hype um all
that stuff they don't have it and
because they don't have that their
project kind of just like it sits in the
dark you know so it's the same way back
you know apple never marketed if amazon
never might never had any advertisements
like it's the exact same thing and that
also scares me like if i can if i'm
looking at that like there's a 21 year
old college dropout and i'm like yo
you dudes need to get your name out
there you need to market and they don't
understand that as like as a project i
don't want to put my money there um and
then the last thing that i look at which
again i think a lot of people overlook
is they invest in a lot of that
doesn't solve any problems you know it's
just it's out there solving a problem
that doesn't exist it's you know why a
big reason why i invested in solana
ethan's you know it's it's
clogged the fees are crazy um
so that's the main reason i went solana
um was because of that they had a solid
team um the hype at the time too like it
was one of the highest rated icos
everyone was trying to get in on that um
and then it was honestly perfect timing
because the bear market hit everyone was
too scared to buy um went sideways for a
bit and then went up so that would be
yeah that would be my last tip is like
make sure what you're investing in
solves a problem if it doesn't solve a
problem there's no use for it you know
what i mean
yeah i think you're right as well
especially about marketing um it's so
important even just like on an
individual level you know you can see
people out there who are less
intelligent than you but are doing
better than you it's because they've
been able to market themselves present
themselves in such a way which is so
attractive to people so yeah marketing
is absolutely huge um but given how the
market is right now i'd love your
thoughts are we in a bear market bull
market
where do you stand
so
i get like all the time now especially
like with the way the market is like
people will be commenting on my stuff
like yo bro it's a bear market bull
market
in my opinion so like the way i look at
it like i don't look at this as like a
monthly thing you know we'll we'll be in
a downtrend for a month people be like
oh it's a bear market confirm bear
market like i don't i'm not looking at
that you know i'm looking at the bigger
picture you know we've been in a clear
uptrend now for a while um i still i
don't think we're in a bear market bear
market um because you know when we're
talking bear market
it's
we don't typically bounce for a couple
years um you know everything's down
negative 90
like that's not the case right now you
know you have all these institutions
like there's still a lot of fomo on to
talk and stuff but do you think that's
just because the market has evolved and
it's not going to be the same type of
bear market 2018 or do you think it's
because we're just not in a bear market
yeah so that was the other thing is that
that's you know that's the other
situation that i potentially see is that
we could be in a bear market but like
you say the markets kind of evolved and
it's not going to be these multi you
know year long bear markets maybe we
just you know six months you know trade
sideways downwards action a little bit
um you know then pop back up but for me
i'm not 100 sure you know whether we go
into a multi-year bear market or like
you say you know markets have evolved so
that's why i always practice
buy
five stuff five fundamentals and just
hold it and either way you know you're
gonna win in a couple years from now um
so in my opinion
i don't know and i think that people
it's also it's so funny to me like
watching all of these people like be
like yeah like you know i'm certain of
this this and that
you actually don't have any idea like
what's going on because at the end of
the day tomorrow russia could drop a
bomb on ukraine and it changes
everything you know
it's so true it's like it's so funny for
me to watch like all this i'm just like
i've kind of like learned now just like
sit back because the outcome is
inevitable so like i said once you've
bought your stuff and you have your
coins and you made your decision to get
in there's not really much else to do
and all this extra stress like paying
attention all this it's unnecessary um
you know you don't need to do it because
again you are not in control like
control of the stuff and it's the same
thing when i'm not into american
football at all but all my friends are i
watch them talk to each other like they
are the coaches and they are the ones
that get to make the decisions on the
field you know oh we should have done
this we should have done that i'm like
but you didn't because you you're not
the coach you can't do anything about it
and it's just like it's it's just as
funny for me to watch
and yeah no i totally hear you and you
said there are all you're doing right
now is you're holding your five coins so
what are those five coins and oh i was
saying i was saying i was saying fire
coins like solid coins my bad
i've got a couple um
i hold so like i'm big on woo network
right now um i know that finance um had
i think it was like
20 or 12 million one of those numbers
with the two in it um like a few weeks
ago they invested um so i'm being on
that that's an exchange and i know like
a while ago
um they were doing like more volume than
coinbase um i know that wasn't
consistent but you know it was it was
there um so we would network i'm big on
nftb
um nft platform same thing backed by
banan's labs they were an early investor
they're getting into like the gaming
space too which i also think is going to
be huge like and we can talk about that
as well but i think the gaming space in
crypto is really early so you know
um
seoul
i'm still home
yeah
i'm still holding some solana um i did
actually take a bunch of profit though
at like 200 which it ended up being like
i pretty much bought the bottom and sold
the top which is crazy because i've
never never done that before so like um
you know everyone we talk about doing
this stuff all the time um but very
rarely do we do it so that's been cool
but i'm still bag holding a little bit
there um and then yeah i've got i had
some luna which i sold because again i
can't
there's just that was you know there's a
guy on a twitter you know wizard he
tried to get me in on that early um and
i didn't i didn't listen to him like
four bucks again i thought i put that
money in solana so like can you really
be that mad um that's the other thing
like yeah like you know everyone feels
like they've missed out but like time
and time again you know the bald apes
punks solana matic axe infinity it's
just shown that there's endless amounts
of life-changing opportunities um but
you need to know about them right like
you need to know you need to be able to
spot them 100 and like any of teens like
that's i don't know what the
going on with nft
like people are asking me i'm just like
i tried i bought a bloody pudgy penguin
for like five eighth i'm getting offers
for like one eath i'm done with that
so like i bought the top then i was just
like what is this so
um i feel like with the nats too
um
i think those are gonna come crashing
down so hard like harder than the meme
coins um because i think it's like the
same people that are just recycling them
you know what i mean like going from
project to project eventually like
people are going to get tired and you
know you're not going to have i think
nfts you know the technology is the
future but not these profile photos left
yes you know these are just like when
you talk about putting um you know
information and stuff like putting
paychecks as nfts and you know having
ids as nfts that for me is the future
not
not the not the profile pictures and
again like board ape and stuff a little
different crazy community but like a lot
of them i think are going to crash and
burn but i agree you have to you have to
know exactly what you're looking for and
again
with influencers be careful because when
you know i see say like for example
my boy faze banks like i'm a big fan of
him but whenever he like tweets about
any nft posts it on his instagram
anything the floor goes crazy instantly
if you get in after the floor's gone
crazy you know there's not new people
buying that you know you've got to be
wary
yeah same thing with the coins gotta
know what to look for
yeah no i'm with you on nfts i think
that um it's definitely a bubble there's
definitely um unnecessary hype but the
technology and the concepts in terms of
giving something a digital id or
authenticating it onto the blockchain
yeah 100 i mean even art like even as
even just digital art i totally see it
um but i want to just like get your
thoughts actually on tick tock because
you mentioned meme coins there and meme
coins were definitely the highlight of
this bull market for me um but what was
going on on tick tock because like
wasn't tick tock pumping all these coins
and it was kind of driving the market at
some point
what happened so again like a lot of a
lot of people don't understand like all
these other which just like it baffles
me because all these people that are
doing this stuff are supposed to be like
really intelligent you know they're
supposed to be developers all this stuff
all these people that ended up creating
these random meme coins and stuff
do not understand how this all started
and how it all started was one kid on
tiktok made one video about safe moon
and being like yo the tokens burn this
and that that one video got 10 million
views why when did
it just the tech talk algorithm and it
was when crypto so that was like you
know when crypto first kind of started
going crazy when we first were heading
up to 60k so that was when you know it
kind of started going mainstream again
for the first time in a while yeah so
like the first time it kind of started
going crazy so this dude was like oh
meme coin first one it burns like this
and that and again i'm never i'm not one
you know to talk too much about it but
like the iqs on tech talk are very low
so it's these kids that are just they
don't understand market cap anything and
they just hear these numbers and they're
like okay bet
they are only putting in
two three hundred four five hundred
dollars but when you get 10 million
views on a video if you even get a one
percent conversion rate of that you know
it's it's crazy so this one kid posted
that video i mean
if he had played this right you know he
would have made
money for
his kids kids kids kids kids um i'm sure
he made bread but i don't think you know
no one was expecting it to go the way it
did but he ended up making one or two
more follow-up videos and it just went
crazy you then had all these other meme
coins and then you know shiba went next
and a few others but then you had all
these other meme coins trying to just do
the exact same thing um
without that viral video and i'm like
that's not how it works you can't just
create the again like and it sucked too
like being half the reason like why like
i chilled out with the influencer stuff
for a bit was because i had like friends
and like people that i knew trying to
get me to like promote their stuff and
i'm like no like and that you know like
especially any of t projects bro this
one's different like actual this this
that no it's not it's all the same thing
and like you're my boy and it's making
me mad because all the blame will fall
on my back you know um so all these i
was like trying to explain that to
people i'm like it's only a matter of
time before your mean coins come
crashing down because also how that
works
until the second that people stop buying
that the price is going down and the
thing is there's no utility so in order
for people to keep buying that coin you
need to have some kid on tick tock every
single month getting 10 million views on
a video the second ad stops happening
your coins are going to and so
especially when i started seeing all
these random other coins coming into the
space i gave it a crack with one or two
lost all my money again same thing
which ones but it was
this coin like moon moon went to zero
yeah nah i mean it's in the name so
again i didn't put a whole lot of money
and i put a disclaimer out there i was
like i'm fully prepared for this to go
to zero and it went to zero people are
still mad but i was like
i don't know what year it's called moon
moon and i say that you know there's a
good chance to go to zero so i don't
know what to tell you so i gave it a
couple cracks didn't work out and so i
was like you know i'm done with this but
the whole meme coin thing
for me and it's the same thing with nft
is like at the beginning i was like oh
you know it's not really a big deal but
like it honestly has to stop in order
for the space to like go forward um like
it's just it's crazy like it gives
it just doesn't give a great look at all
you know and i know we have like the
biden administration supposed to be
rolling out some regulations like real
soon so like things like that
if we get shitty regulations it's gonna
be because of meme coins and you know
all this random stuff and i remember
posting videos on tech talk being like
do not buy this you know it's it's
not real and there was this one specific
dude that created his own meme coin a
tech talker that had no idea what he was
doing he copy and pasted the code said
it he named it scam like like a scam
coin and i was like don't buy this he
tried he's like oh let me send you some
i was like no i don't want any of that
yeah i made a video and i was like yo if
you guys buy this stuff you're going to
lose all your money the responses that i
got were actually like incredible like
people wanted to take my head off when i
spoke badly about shiba inu people were
livid and they were just like they were
so confident that it was going up
and you know fast forward now it's
everyone's like oh okay like no more
meme coins like tik tok like as a whole
has grown up but like six months ago
like they were fully just like oh no
it's all good like meme coins meme coins
and
it was never going to end well and you
know that's like a lot of people like oh
we didn't have a blow off top we didn't
have a blow off top that could have very
well been the blow off top you know you
had these mean coins going berserk you
know like you say the markets evolved
blow off top just might be in a
different form but yeah that was that
was absolutely crazy and
that was when tech talk even cracked
down like on like their crypto
guidelines and everything yes i remember
for me like you know i know there's no
regulations and stuff on this market yet
and you know you can legally yes you can
go and talk about crypto but i'm
wondering to myself especially like a
lot of like the tick tockers and stuff
that got paid to talk about stuff and at
rug to zero
surely there's got to be legal consul
like surely somewhere down the line like
you have to be held recountable i don't
know like otherwise i think i think some
are but only like only the celebrities i
know that i saw kim kardashian and some
other celebrities are being sued for
promoting
eth
max
is that what it was called yeah well
funny thing about eth max or ethmaxy or
something i know exactly the one you're
talking about i saw it on a story and i
was suck
but i was at so there's this uh house in
los angeles it's called
it's something house like but so what
they do is they have uh like a bunch of
different kids come from startup
companies and they'll do it once a month
and they rotate like a new group of
people once a month and ultimately like
you live in this house together and you
all like bounce ideas off of each other
and help each other with your startups
and so like it's cool and i went
there for one of one of their events
they won dinner and i met
this dude that was he starts talking to
me and he's like oh like you're in a
crypto like because not many people were
crypto there it was mostly just like
business like orientated
so starts talking to me he's like oh
like have you ever promoted coins and i
was like no i really this man he's like
oh look i'm the guy that sets them up
i was like
what do you mean like i get talking to
her like he doesn't want to give me his
name or anything we get further down the
line and like i'm not shy so i got
straight up asked him i was like dude
you're a scammer like he's like no but
like there was this one project like a
therian max that i was in charge of and
like and he pretty much just said yeah
that that he rugged everyone and like
this dude doesn't show his face or
anything but he gets like they just get
these telegram group chats he was
telling me
get a bunch of people on it um get them
to pay influences they'll pump it and
then just rug it oh my god are you not
afraid of going to jail he's like no not
really like you can't track it this and
it was honestly made me live it i was
just standing there and i was like i
want to sock you but i can't do that
that is crazy yeah yeah i know i know my
brother was actually out in l.a like a
few months ago and he was telling me how
they were they were creating these new
coins and pumping them to like hundreds
or hundreds of thousands and then just
yeah
absolutely every single week like the
amount of people that i have
like
on just like in my dms that will fight
like they first found me on tech talk
and like they'll start you know oh bro
like love your videos like they're so
funny this and that then a week later oh
bro like i have this nft project like
can you promote it this and that and
it's just like every single one of them
if it doesn't rug now it's gonna happen
just because these people cannot keep up
with these unrealistic road maps and
expectations like i don't know if you
know about like the milk boys and like
no he's the milk boys so like they're
like a big like uh like youtuber um
um yeah so like they they kind of their
main age group i'd say it's a little bit
younger than me um
but they pretty much just launched an
nft project and they they their nft
minted for 0.75 each i believe they sold
10 000 sold out instantly and they made
23 million off the drop and so their
project what they are saying is
with their utility the whole you know
the whole
drive towards it is they're gonna build
gyms and throw festivals this and that
there's a shitload of red flags for one
the contract was not verified which is
just bizarre you know it's like okay so
they put out a whole thing like we're
gonna make sure we're doing this right
this and that they announced the release
of the nft project and then the mint
would was the very next day so like
there's there was that red flag um
there's the one that they went i watched
last night i went and looked at all the
wallets the team was sweeping the floor
which is
just you know after the team initially
dumped as it listed um they had sam
pepper and their friends and family
which i don't know if you know but sam
pepper he was behind like save the kids
which was a meme coin that rugged um
very well-known scammer in the space um
so i don't know why you know they would
have him in there that's crazy and
against yeah so it's like i'm looking
i'm i like the milk boys i'm rooting for
them i'm not saying it's a scam i don't
think you know you can say it's a scam
just yet because they all make all these
big promises and stuff who knows maybe i
mean with 23 million dollars you
probably could pull it off but also
there's a lot of questions like to be
answered like for example the majority
of their fan base i don't think is
definitely not 21 years old therefore
they cannot go to these music festivals
to these clubs that are going to be 21
and up you know so there's
there's i mean that you have lana rhodes
2 who dropped her like nft collection
which i don't even know what that is to
do with but like everyone is
yeah like it's just like they have same
thing as uh trump's missus i forget her
first name but
um what's her name oh wow now that's
gone from my head melania or millennials
thank you melania yeah one of them like
i saw that she had like a 99 royalty i
don't know if that was real but i was
just like 99 royalty on our nfts and i
was like
how is this even a thing and like you
have her like tweeting about like
bitcoin and all this stuff now but she
just has some pr dude like they don't
even know what's going on so
it it's for me like this market almost
needs like a little bit of a flush but
you know just going back like i'm same
thing like i don't know if like milk
boys like if that project fails surely
they're gonna have to deal with legal
consequences like that's essentially you
know you could look at it that's a 23
million dollar raise like that is
like institutions taking that kind of
money so it's like they've gone and done
that and promised all you know these big
things so
we'll see how it happens but yeah the
nfts and a lot of people are asking me
right now how hard i get into them this
and that they've been popping for a
little bit now i don't know if i'd be
getting in just yet um again i don't own
any apes or any punks or anything i
still believe that we go through a bear
market at least you know like an nft
bear market that's like the time to buy
you know when everyone's when everyone's
themselves no one wants to pick
up like it just it can't go up forever
you know just like we've seen with
bitcoin you know what goes up must come
down
yeah i'm with you i don't even i'm
waiting for a confirmed bear market
before i ape into basically everything
um i'm totally ready for it um but i
want to move on a little bit and talk
about el salvador so i know you have
some thoughts there um so nayeon pickely
like he is wild his tweets are just
insane um i read a tweet yesterday and
ever there was like three lines and
every line just shocked me as i kept
going and i kept i was like what am i
reading um is he gambling the country's
money
i think he's a lunatic because really i
think he's a lunatic because he reminds
me of myself
but
here's the problem you know i am not the
president of a country um i'm a 21 year
old dropout
who's still living near the university
um so it's just like i see the things
that he's doing
and
one we are like we're no longer early in
my opinion you know when
i gave
my junior year of high school which was
that is you know sick almost your last
year of high school second or last year
like i was given presentations on
bitcoin and my classes and stuff
whenever i got the opportunity you know
to present whatever we wanted to
everyone was looking at me like i was
crazy no one had heard of it that was
early you know now when my uber driver's
asking me about it and stuff like that's
no longer early so you have the
president of a nation a not so wealthy
nation that's like
loading up
on bitcoin that is
like you said like you even like you
said it yourself you're waiting for a
confirmed bear market yeah um
he's just like loading up on and i don't
know like the first time he started
buying but it got to have been close to
the top um
i'm he's definitely down overall um and
you know essentially for me the way i'm
looking at it is he's either gonna be a
hero or he's gonna wipe el salvador off
the face of the earth because i mean
what if biden comes in you know and he
drops awful regulations and we do go
down for your two years like can i solve
the door like hang on for you know what
i mean so it's like you have just
especially coming from south africa like
i've seen like what these nations look
like you know you can't really afford to
just be
holding like you know i'm going to
school and stuff i can afford to put my
portfolio away for two years and just
not look at it you know
i feel like the dude has not done as you
do like just doesn't know really like
what he's doing essentially i feel like
he's one of us like he's at the gym like
he's just like buying it but i'm like
dog you are the president of a country
at the same time and i hope it works out
for him because that means it works out
for me um you know
but
do you think he's selling like is he
selling i think didn't they buy around
like
around like 58 60k maybe they stole but
maybe they sold at 68k i just i don't i
don't know i don't know i have no idea
um but i also think too like it's a
little concerning like i thought it was
funny like when you know he gave moody's
the middle finger but yeah also same
thing again that's something that i
would do as a college dropout i don't
know if i'd give moody's the middle
finger as the president of a country
when they downgrade me you know because
i'm doing i'm doing things out of the
blue um again i'm i'm a very big fan of
going against the grand so
respect to him you know i'm i'm
struggling to sleep some nights so i
have no idea how this dude is going to
bed um
i just think that you know it's it's the
first time we've ever really seen
anything like it happen
and i think a lot of it kind of depends
on
what happens a lot of it short term is
going to depend what you know what
happens with biden and these you know
these regulations um and i know the us
the second that i'll solve the door made
bitcoin illegal tend to everything
already like you know i forget what they
did but like they weren't with
it you know they were not a fan um so
i'm very curious to see what happens
it's kind of like a tick i think we'll
have our answer pretty soon because
again like you know the third world
nation you can't just keep buying the
dip and it just not go up you know it
has to go up very shortly um i do love
what they're doing like i watched like
the youtube video on like the little
town um that they took like a few years
ago and everything you know there's on
crypto the payments um they got the one
atm there i think that's dope um and if
you could do that you know on a larger
scale that would be cool
um
again i think that he could do what he's
trying to do
but i would rather wait for a better
time you know like this stuff's not
going anywhere soon like nfts all this
stuff i think we're still really early
um again 2.0 hasn't even come out yet i
just think that he could have timed it a
little better you know um yeah same
thing i mean
it's crazy yeah
because i i just because like i'm
sitting here and like i'm nervous
and
i'm just like trying to put myself same
thing as michael saylor like he's got to
be an alcoholic at this point like
there's no way
that he's just sitting there do you
think he's chill
i mean like i think he is but like at
the same like i'm pretty chill most of
the time but also like you always got
that thought in the back of your head
and i'm also not buying billions on
leverage so like that's pretty
incredible um you know i
i don't think
i just think no matter how good you are
at this stuff and i think it's something
that people need to realize like
unless you know you once once you've
pulled your initial like money the money
that you need to take care of yourself
until you've done that it's going to be
stressful and i feel like el salvador
certainly hasn't done that you know um
especially like you say if they got in
at 58k i mean if they got in at 50 ak
and sold 68 that's absolutely incredible
um then you know the president's a god
and he should open up you know he should
open up a cue coin account on my on my
referral link but yeah
i don't know you know um at the same
time too
ksi went down
five million dollars this year which i
thought was incredible um i considered
you know 2021 to be free money i thought
that this was just
you know
everyone was making money and when ksi
retweeted that i was like this is you
know just to show the importance of this
i hope and i'm i doubt that he'll do it
but i hope that you know that the
president of el salvador will never get
involved with leverage um
but
you know
that's a scary that's a scary thing to
do i think at least you know the way the
president's going about it just buy and
hold the safest way that you could go
about it um but yeah i'm very interested
to see the outcome i think it'll be
interesting for the history books for
sure
yeah i mean i'm rooting for them i
really hope it works because i think
that
in terms of timing timing it that would
just be impossible we just can't time
the market i mean ideally now would be a
great time to sort of announce that
you're going to accept bacon's legal
tender add it to your balance sheet and
so on but like
oh country's reserves but i don't know
you just can't time it i'm really
rooting for them i hope you know i hope
it does work out um
but just kind of moving forward changing
subjects a little bit um in terms of you
your career like what is the goal then
at this point because you don't want a
nine-to-five you don't want a boss you
are ground on socials you're obviously
trading well swing trading so what
what's the goal for you so the goal for
me right now is i took a break from
doing like youtube and stuff um i used
to just like vlogs and like funny skits
and just like it's like random stuff um
i stopped doing that for a while um and
i'm actually gonna start that back up
this week i'm recording my first video
um so i'm gonna do that and that was
like that's honestly like one of my
favorite things to do because it's kind
of just like you know you record you
doing you um and you know you get paid
to do so so like um the plan is to get
back on that i really want to start
grinding youtube um and again so many
people like i think that if i can really
commit um you know i get a good editor a
good videographer like i can blow up
because it's again it's just all
consistency um and just posting like a
lot of people just don't do it um you
just have to do it so canada's
definitely move forward with that um
and then just continue honestly to so
what i've been doing with like
especially while the market's so
volatile like a lot of people are scared
but when you get these negative 30 dumps
prime example you know woo dumped all
the way to like 49 cents or something i
checked this morning it's already back
up to 65 cents so you know you don't
have to time it perfectly but
when some are like my favorite alts are
down like 25 30 percent i will you know
load up with some spot and i'll just
wait for the leaf bounce wait you know
10 15 anywhere there sell it um and then
that kind of keeps me busy because again
the whole the hard part about this you
know with the investing is you just you
can't touch it you just buy it
you leave it um it's very boring you
know you can't do anything so like the
swing trading kind of keeps me active a
little bit um tech talk i don't know if
we're gonna go forward with that just
because
so much drama um
and then maybe i don't know we'll see
how far the bodybuilding goes um just
you know i'm curious just like again
being like a fat kid my whole life like
it's kind of cool like to be doing she
did it yeah keep it up yeah no 100 it's
also kind of just like show people like
you because i mean i was obese like i
was uh i was not in the best shape at
all you should i don't know if i haven't
seen but if you put a picture up on
twitter of what you were like before
yeah it was it was it was it was ugly
it's somewhere up there i'll drop i'll
drop another one you should do it again
do a before and after have you ever seen
like the michelin man like the dude the
dude that advertised for like for the
thai company it looks like a giant
marshmallow that's right i'm gonna come
up really quickly anyway what about the
michelin man how do i spell that oh i
have no idea
but he's like a tire like a like a tire
guy um one of them i like that yeah
that's how i was looking
oh wow
yeah not great um you well that's
amazing you should upload you should
upload that i want to see that no 100 so
yeah that's why that's why i kind of
wanted to start youtube again and just
like document it um
because people just like
you people don't understand like your
mental health like and physically like
that starts everything um and like
you go even deeper into it like talk
about like foods and stuff like the
reason why in my opinion like the
ultimate downfall which like i know a
lot of people will get this but like the
ultimate downfall of society is going to
be the food that we're eating um
since the 80s male testosterone has
dropped one percent like every single
year um you know it's no longer men 20
years ago look like men versus today you
have these 25 year olds on tik tok that
look 16 it's because their testosterone
is on the floor and you know when you've
got low testosterone you're depressed
you're lazy um and a lot of this comes
from like the food and that we're
eating today so it's like you know you
feel like you're not going to be
able to work you're not going to be able
to make money you're not going to want
to go out you're not going to have the
energy to talk to girls guys whatever it
may be so like i think a lot of people
overlook that but it literally starts
from like step one
yeah no you're totally right yeah like
my trading everything like that's why i
got back into the gym you know like a
month two months ago was because like i
noticed that i didn't have as much
energy it wasn't you know i wasn't
watching the markets wasn't doing as
much research um and so like i find it
crazy that in canada i saw that maine on
twitter tweeted that their gyms have
only just opened up like a week ago like
that to me is insane because gyms aren't
essential business like it cures
depression you know if you're gonna
if you're gonna hand out opioids and all
this and that at the same time like you
have to allow people to go to the gym
like that is my form that is how i go
and like you know it's not that not that
i'm depressed but it just makes you feel
good you know like you just like you
ready to move on with your day um and
it's like i just i notice if i don't
work out i don't feel as good like i
don't i don't feel like i've done
anything i haven't achieved anything you
know
yeah i'm totally with you i think
there's so much wrong society now that's
a podcast for another time um
low testosterone the food you know girls
looking like guys guys looking like
girls but um
yeah crazy i don't know where we're
going
again
people like like they rarely worry over
this stuff like yeah for me like i'm not
too worried just because it's again
outcomes inevitable i cannot there's
nothing no matter how hard i work for
the rest of my life no matter what
position i get to i'm not going to be
able to do anything about this you know
society's going to be society it's going
to do its thing and like i see a lot of
people complaining all the time i'm like
yeah if you hate it that much just move
off the grid you know go live on like a
little farm and do your thing then and
then you can live by yourself and you
see how you like it but
i think the best thing to do is just
make enough money so that you are
independent and immune from whatever
society is going through
and then surround yourself with
like-minded people because there are
enough people who see the world um in a
similar way so um
yeah
i feel like that number's growing too
especially
all the that's going on like oh
yeah i was never so much like yo like if
the system this and that like i'm fully
now like i'm not with it at all like
it's just like after all this like
especially me moving to you know the
whole reason i moved here with my family
originally six years ago was the
corruption and all the from south
africa africa yeah and so i was
originally i was born in zimbabwe so
like a little further up left zimbabwe
because you know it was going down the
toilet south africa then started going
down the toilet came to the us
then realize that see the thing that
upsets me about the us like africa like
they're so bad at hiding their
corruption and stuff you know it's
happening like it's blatantly obvious
it's right there in your face so like
you're not if it makes sense like you're
not that upset you know you know it's
going to happen so it's like you know
the outcome it's like bet like you know
my taxes are going there whatever the us
i've learned has
far more corruption than africa will
ever have the thing is they are just
better at hiding it um which is more
painful to me and you know you don't
need any further proof than looking at
all the uh the beautiful democrats and
republicans that outperform the aspy you
know it's absolutely
it's incredible so um
that to me was a big eye-opener i was
just like damn you know everywhere is
kind of uh everywhere's got its problems
and you kind of just
for me like at least in the u.s i'm safe
which is you know number one priority um
south africa is not that safe of a place
johannesburg is like one of the most
violent cities in you know in the whole
world it's crazy um so that was one
thing that i learned but yeah the us
very good at hiding their corruption um
and the one thing i really get in uh
rapping and patriotism and
i really like hate like too like how the
us it's just uh
it's more everything's become about
politics like it's no longer about the
truth at all you know you got news
channels fighting each other like it's
crazy it's you got full grown adults
acting like little kids
and it's just like it baffles my mind
i'm just like you know you guys do you
well i really appreciate you coming on
um your insight is really interesting um
i loved everything that you had to say i
think you're so on the right path i
think you see the world in the correct
way so i'm super excited to see what you
do um you know in the next in the next
few years so where can people find you
and follow you
so um you can find me on twitter at
cousin crypto um spot with zero at the
end and then i have a podcast heinous
pumps that i've just started in the last
few weeks
me and one of my boys he's another
student at arizona state um so it's
pretty cool you know you get to listen
to two kids living during covert and all
this so you know i kind of get to
see it from our eyes
um and then instagram josh.bryant um be
posting on youtube too jaybiz athletics
gonna be all over the place uh 2022 is a
year for social media for sure
amazing guys definitely go follow um
cousin crypto some amazing insight there
thank you so much for coming on it's
been great to have you thank you so much
for having me i had an awesome time
for sure guys don't forget to subscribe
hit the like button and tune in for
another great guest next week we'll see
you then
[Applause]
[Music]